et tu as des couilles est à des varices
ma récente um est benhaim us rochus
s'était dès lors que des harry potter
[Musique]
non non non non non parce que là j'ai
très peur j'ai très peur il glisse très
mal votre portable alors bâtonnier pour
qu'elle bat attendit vocal bat nom n'a
personne à personne le web elle était au
bout parce qu'elle ait voulu me voir
là bas avec le téléphone attention il
faut que vous gagnez de points
donc déjà si vous mettez un point et
attention ne pas dépasser très loin non
si vous avez vraiment on sait jamais
jimena et reste ça
attends je peux lui montrer eux
mais là il part dans sa patoche
recensé pour vous que je le fais tu
syrie
mais là il me sentant du
napa 200 boulettes
nazis mais là
ça va ça
oui les chevals
0 à toi toi
les foley mais pénalité soit d'une
mauvaise foi
elle me tais coupe tu me dégoûtes
opéré s'est passé un laissez passer est
ce que le public pourrait montcoy je
suis
[Applaudissements]
bonjour les gars quand même aux côtés de
guillaume
c'est quand même moi qui vais payer
et pas peur
il m'a dit tu gardes ton portable de
guillaume
du
bâtiment va
gérer on appelle chier dessus
la peur de gagner au canada la peur de
perdre mentale pas de mental j'essaie
d'aller humains qu'ils fassent moins
après ça fera un partout ce magasin
tandis ou encore il est vrai que j'ai
pas confiance enfin si on vous que la
ram et le portage ces pages de son
chouchou j'ai envie de faire comme ça
je crois que c'est mieux comme ça arrive
toi ça fait les touchent at on pu durant
des verrues
mal agencé de traiter dépêche-toi
allonger le bras non mais attendez
[Applaudissements]
je fais de la
distraire
illicites au portable il est allé à die
les shérifs fait poser une question
publics patronats maintenant qu'on a un
parc c'est le public qui va décider est
ce que vous voulez que ce soit bénigne
qui vous fasse gagner ou moi on va faire
le troisième essai
je marque un public
de sortir et d'aller se concerter parole
après concertation nous viendrait me
voir je ferai un mail à la direction
qui sont les gens parce que je vous dire
il va falloir vous prenez décision
commune a devancé roussy et valérie qui
vous fait gagner le portable si elles
gagnent un levé ou c'est moi ah ouais
d'accord ces conflits avaient compris
arriver tu as compris
l'église à lime rock pas de mon gros
vous croyez en satin noir moi quoi
exactement le shérif walt non dans le
public on va on va jouer sauf que c'est
ce qui crée non le plus qui veut se soit
benhaim qui les représentent
c'est pas mal qui veut que je les
représente
voudra-t-il encore à l'oreille c'est de
nîmes
je vais demander à un spécialiste à
l'oeil c'est qui a goûté merci à china
donc le record qui gagne il gagne si je
gagne ok vous gagner si je perds vous
perdez vous allez vous en mordre les
doigts sauf que maintenant j'en sais
mais ça t'évite ça parce que tu vois là
prendre une statue en or à partir de là
ça m'arrivait dans le pif
c'est vrai donc voile et les amoureux
représentait plus que moi je suis une
merde
non mais c'est vrai est ce qu'on voulait
que vela valérie débats c'est pas des
béquilles moment présent le portois la
blessure de oui c'est sûr mignola
lorsque c'est vrai que toi tu peux rien
faire avec ce fait perdre alors que moi
je suis une mère mais je me dégoûte
je me dégoûte gérer at home je me
dégoûte alors beinheim alors si mais bon
c'est toi qui vas ont fait daniel en
deuxième
alors 2e derrière toi donc oui
ok donc on est d'accord que je joue pour
le public oui tu joues pour le public
sur un chouchou d'action avant tout une
joue pas pour le public
joue pour la france
en vrai que j'ai dit la vérité - de jeu
pour le plaisir de t'écraser
[Applaudissements]
toujours pour le plaisir de ne pas
devoir en 2010
aimant la déception sera gros
et angoisse j'ai l'âme inquiéterait
l'emploi à
baba
est ce que pouvaient voter mais pas de
vote majorque ici s'il vous plaît
voilà vous diront jamais entendu
merci cas vous êtes très beau tout en
blue jeans comme ça tellement que tu
perdes ah oui ah ouais mais y croit
tellement pas est ce qu'on peut faire un
tour de table des chroniqueurs passent
alors ils croient en qui alors déjà vous
ne montrez pas comme ceux des jours
vous plaît gilles vous allé écraser
benhaim est bien fait pour sa gueule
je demande d'augmentation pour gilles
vous serez commenté isabelle machette
vous parce que je suis ici mais je suis
pas mais merci isabelle je demande 10
ans plus d'espérance de vie
beaucoup plus compliqué avoir
qu'augmentation isa merci bernard
montiel à moi je suis sûr que c'est vous
en plus j'aurais une augmentation donc
je suis sûr augmentation pas manqué mais
géraldine maillet un afflux de
l'augmentation vous êtes beaucoup trop
arrogant c'est valérie qui magasin faire
je vais demander à toutes les jeunes
demandent à toutes les personnes qui
nous regardent de bien regarder
géraldine maillet
[Rires]
voilà si on voulait faire des photos
d'échelle comme ça
jamais connu
tu vas pas besoin lui demandez pas rien
à [ __ ] de l'augmentation je vote pour
le talent je vote pour série mercy ok ça
ça va leur
boulot l'asticot jean-pierre que des
chanteurs joker très bien bon d'accord
il a raté mon téléphone vote pour toi
pour valérie mes recettes schepper du
téléphone c'est à dire s'il voit la peur
prend celui que tu déteste le plus c'est
parce que je sens que tu as peur là mais
j'ai peur de l'eau c'est vous
c'est elle qui va gagner mercier n'a
jamais habité achats pas là
et voilà ils sont bons dans ce qu'ils
font mais en pronostics ça fait une
capestang
excusez moi vous allez rangée du bétail
mais sans déconner le bas jamais sur
mamy
noda le greffe de en pick up le gagnant
pick up au studio quoi avec du bétail
derrière quoi non mais sans déconner
c'est de dire alors déjà quoi s'il vous
plaît ce petit on l'a ouais moi on est
on est on est pas sur wii flandre
attentes s'il ya des règles alors c'est
quoi pas pour autant d'aller dire
j'aimerais beaucoup dormir à boulogne
lors d'une soirée amicale
donc je vais dire vous quoi ouais ouais
dans le cumul
augmentation je serai toujours derrière
toi
non vraiment emmerde pas vraiment lourde
- chopra moi je préfère d'abord à l'oeil
je me rappelle ce n'est qu'une seule
amie vrai autour de la table c'est jade
non sur la mettrait alors attention ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il ne vous aime pas
celle espérée bien ça veut dire qu'on
n'aime pas
castaldi benjamin bien évidemment pour
vous au sûr il enfin
on est comme ça lui va bien sûr et moi
j'entends lui il voit un diot
canivez d'aubry je sais qu'il va dire
benhaim pourquoi ce qu'elle veut parce
que c'est beau tout seul ami je pense
non alors valérie a failli vous défoncer
hier et je crois pour aujourd'hui merci
à l'écrit
mais de donner tant pis est autant que
ça tombe à l'eau mais mon rêve à moi
est faux que sa tombe voilà ouais tu
fais
yvonne enjoignent est sûre c'est vite
c'est un moment très grave
sommes dans le jeu du téléphone
mais naim insulté traîné dans la boue
envoyez des boulettes à la tête
mais naim ne pense qu'à une seule chose
m'écraser comme une punaise et faire
gagner le public mais naim pour
l'instant
concentrez-vous sur vous
avec un grand v
comme des vaches à lait
bien sûr si tu serais plus mais la hume
si vous gagnez ouais le public partira
pour trois jours en europe l'europe le
phare nien la cordillère des andes
[Rires]
magnifique
wen als
l'iodé diallo mais pas en europe riom
ont coûté que vous serez spéciale est
toujours là
mais naim ouais je vais lancer ce
téléphone alésienne ce téléphone je ne
lance pas pour moi
je lance pour l'éternité hollande c'est
bon c'est bon c'est magnifique ça veut
rien dire
[Rires]
je suis au lit non rien la postérité de
la postérité et également tous les
postérieurs
ram doudyla ignore
hamdoulilah porte des lilas à temps les
incantations maintenant
à la pression quand même un goût un peu
chez moi tu peux pas la totale
a pas d amis dans public dans
l'établissement si chaque pays affirmant
sur le front un arrêt d'accord c'est
l'émotion m'a grave ou sinon ça va vous
avez déjà envoyé des cv pour aujourd'hui
et vacances pour ça ont fêté en
tant qu elle pas sur la table
benayou plaît je vais arrêter là non
mais c'est mon lait aux larves et ya je
ne sais pas les critiques d'un gentil
c'est bon
allez
j'ai la mère noël en bout de table
magnifique appelé m'a regardé on a le
père noël et la mère noël
bien mieux regarder leurs enfants
est magnifique ah oui majhi vous êtes
beau
chez nos pressions la puce c'est pour
faire peur depuis que ça fait beaucoup
de peine les gars ouais bah je vous le
dis oui ça me fait beaucoup de peine
c'est pas bon c'est pas moi
je vais prendre un risque évalué un
beauf maïs et de l'orge et le foot quand
votre gueule
plusieurs heures jeudi un marathon télé
durant
la captation il paraît que ça prend
l'eau oui ouais non mais c'est vrai il
doit ses voitures feront petite bassine
sexactu c'est ce mot que chercher à
bien enroulé au
verbe
à 2h30 là elle est belle la montre là
[Applaudissements]
mais tullow la
[Musique]
médaille
[Applaudissements]
oui tous et pas de toucher à votre cure
non non non personne là bas cenon
période le ramassera le téléphone kelly
je vous demander de partir personne ne
ramassera téléphone mettez vous en ayez
confiance à personne ne ramassera
téléphone me thibout la
personne on ramassera ce téléphone fixe
téléphone tombe il périra
s'il meurt vous le rencontrez pas je ne
rembourseraient rien car je suis un rat
mort
[Rires]
le premier une pression supplémentaire
je suis ça met une pression
supplémentaire et une année une pensée
pour abandonner tout de suite donc
viendra pas non et dire non mais quand
sûrs - oui
[Applaudissements]
j'ai un duel à vous faire un big ben à
quoi tient au public il va choisir où
on regarde mon portable ici ou et j'ai
gagné cauchon et j'ai gagné et j'offre à
tout le public quoi vous avez peur que
je me batte en fait à tout le public le
voyage on nous achète ou bien bien bien
mais c'est un voyage de trois jours
c'est un voyage de trois heures
possible
ou bien vous passez tous trois heures
d'aller très vite un vous faites à chuck
c'est à dire qu'ils achètent yahoo
d'acheter une route des monts venez quoi
toi est l'option numéro revient à
l'option numéro 2 faites confiance à
bélaye au risque de tout perdre
marina est ce que vous choisissez dans
ce que vous soyez ces deux jours au lieu
de trois où vous choisissez mes narines
avec qui veut vraiment pas que je joue
contre temps mais pas du tout je demande
au public parce que moi j'ai mon public
si vous n'aimez pas le public d'en
dégoûter pas les autres je comprends
c'est où vous partez tous deux jours au
lieu de trois ou bien vous prenez le
risque grave est que benhaim cela et
faire nos biens votre chance et ouest et
trois jours mais vous prenez le risque
bella une paire de tous et que benhaim
vous gâchent notre nouvelle année et
votre vie et votre vie
reprendre les deux jours tout de suite
que benali me tente le coup
[Applaudissements]
le public a pris le risque et je vous le
dis oh là on ne pourra plus revenir en
arrière
vous avez tort tiens pas l'agression ne
faut pas faire ça elle est tête de
perdre entre garde
[Applaudissements]
écoute le publie des transferts aller
mais naim est maintenant à vous de
prendre vos responsabilités
tu comptais clic teklak était quelqu'un
que tu dégages
au plénum
a dû interrompre le sien et le bras sous
[Rires]
je vais entendre plouf
bon écoute parce apatow arrête un bon ça
papa tâche en slip au monoprix
ya patachou slib aaa à
nathan soit pas de
le surpasser même terre et me cacher la
mapad ou alors vous êtes pas du tout tu
sois pas patauge la papatte âge il n'a
pas pas tâche
[Applaudissements]
malheureusement
[Musique]
jeu et c'est indépendant de ma volonté
j'étais content là il y a eu ce qu'on
appelle un vice de forme non mais
malheureusement
non allez vous asseoir valérie parce que
l'heure est grave
ouais c'est le 2 mai une heure de
l'émission le code d'honneur de
l'émission a été bafouée et c'est paco
non pas ici
médaille vous avez mangé
géo montre exactement ce qui s'est passé
mais qu'est ce qu'il va me sens et vous
allez me dire quelle horreur
malheureusement le public ne partira pas
j'ai tout donné mais on veut des preuves
vous avez en clair
s'il vous plaît est-ce que tu admires
coutume donne des preuves
je ne crois pas
j'ai un public vous savez que j'ai
toujours été avec vous malheureusement
aujourd'hui du doigt vous tourner le dos
à cause d'une personne qui a
malheureusement tricher oui vraiment
valérie bénaïm non mais tu plaisantes à
niort footing ma gueule
ya bien sûr s'est précisée dans le
règlement que quand le téléphone tourne
sur lui même ses annuaires
[Applaudissements]
le téléphone affiche
alors que le téléphone google pourquoi
guillaume genton connais les règles et
pape ni le téléphone doit faire ça
malheureusement valérie bénaïm oui il
avait fait exprès mais à l'épaisseur et
l'article 12 beinheim
benhaim ça va être très simple and
honour benhaim technique benhaim si j'ai
fait ça pénalise le public avec moi et
on se barre alors
bref vous disent quelque chose
[Applaudissements]
bon d'accord
on n entendra nanou la démission d'un
public
goûter jeux merci après tout ce que j'ai
fait pour vous bravo
m'avez élu pour cinq ans
et je vais vous dire
le vote il se fait dans l'urne et non
pas dans la rue
juste au bétail mairie si vous voulez
sortir
n'hésitez pas mais je prends un public
adéquat aux médailles sachez juste une
chose ce que toute sortie est définitive
après sur oued c'est moche si vous dire
que si vous sortez vous savez quoi vous
ne reviendrait plus jamais vous hésitez
pas de pouvoir c'est ben c'est pas du
tout mon pouvoir si le règlement
alemtuzumab
artix et là dessus on peut voir les
statuts le règlement à sarzeau et ce
n'est pas d'assurer d'ouvrir il a bien
démarré statue au musée ne va pas chez
eux il est là règlement si vous le
voulez bien
le temps
mais c'est honteux
non mais kim jong hossein mir puccia
conseil des ministres tenu quelques
instants
beinheim
malheureusement non mais t'es sérieux là
sur votre performance est invalidée et
vous allez faire part de la public
passerait d'un petit ego mais naïma je
vous ai battus mais là je vais vous dire
quelque chose
est ce que vous dites nous ce que vous
dites peut-être ont tous battu madame je
voulais aller ça va là et eux les deux
là sont isolés est vrai non mais sans
déconner est cerise de groupama et
l'autre là où les hommes
est
vrai alors alors je peux l'écouter
mais ces crimes qui n'ont pas ça tourne
alors
dans son seul nom mais
je vais te dire deux groupes auxerre
s'était créé où il faut pas que sa tâche
est écrit sur les murs à l'encré de noël
[Applaudissements]
etc et united l'avait écrit nos espoirs
en forme de graffitis
beinheim oui
je savais le public vous regardez la
jugeant tout ce que l'on était peut-être
autant on peut se retourner qu'on ait
recommencé de quoi médaille je vais vous
dire un truc aujourd'hui tout le monde
sait vous faites partie maintenant des
faits divers de la télévision
les impostures mais naim elle fait
partie bientôt il y aura en dessous de
votre nom ou arnaque vol
l'escroquerie on va par y croire ces
sacs benhaim
vous avez lamentablement tricher mais
incroyable mais naim aujourd'hui je vois
le public est dépité nul n'est censé
ignorer le règlement regarder et tout ça
et pourquoi publique et député ce qui
l'est tout simplement déçu il est déçu
parce que benhaim les a déçus sont ni
comment une personne en qui on avait une
telle confiance a pu tricher
écoutez écoutez il faut c'est mon père
je connais le public quand il dit non
c'est qu'il dit oui
[Rires]
le public
je sais et je me tourne vers vous le
public je sais que vous êtes déçu par
valérie
[Musique]
les cherry hill valérie a triché non
écoutez laissez moi finir
à l'aider à tricher mais
vous savez je ne vous ai jamais lâché et
je vais peut-être faire quelque chose
que je n'ai jamais fait
vous quand malgré cette triche on en
rêve
je vais peut-être vous envoyer en europe
juste j'aimerais juste que vous aviez
tout ce que valérie affichée
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mantei atout le public la corruption de
crème de se laver et de crier non avant
top mais naim la tricheuse
jeu je vous dis je vais vous dire moi
j'aime les gens franc honnête ah oui
et 3 à sion j'aime effet pas fait j'aime
que tout soit transparent et je préfère
une faute avouée qui sera complètement
pardonner
plutôt que de rester dans les non dits
et qui est toujours ce truc entre nous
autres mais les deux mémoires à la crise
il y aura toujours ce petit truc je vais
lui dire bonjour mais ça sera pas un bon
jour prend
je préfère qu'on se dise les choses ce
séjour tu es demandé qu'on leur mette
dans l'écran
il vous tend la main trois jours
d'escapade
d'escapades wii en europe
le vieux continent on a là des
incontinents ton à le vieux continent
gâtés déchets rien c'est patoche
des marques et pataugent qui débarque
mais ne pourra rien pour vous
malheureusement
le public je vais vous laisser
maintenant cinq secondes de réflexion
à mon top on verra ce que vous avez
décidé et si vous avez pris la bonne
décision et vous partirez pour un beau
et long voyage vous corrompre
les témoins musique n'était pas quelque
chose à la corruption en musique s'il ya
encore quelque chose ou quelqu'un
hambrégie s'il vous plaît
c'est ça que vous avez trouvé
les mecs excusez-moi j'ai dit du second
temps si
je vais faire le décompte one vous
emmerdez pas lui enlever moi cette
musique de bon ben là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
savez vous décider
attention tous ceux qui pensent que mal
aimé des maths riche et soulève
en vous est formidable vraiment
malheureusement malheureusement le
public jeudi se sont levés parts on va
prendre le nom
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ce qu'est ce qu'ils ont sur la belle est
élevée on va prendre le nom vos
coordonnées vous allez partir et et on
va défalquer tous les autres jours et
vous partie mais plus longtemps
tous s'activent sur le bo va prendre vos
noms de vos coordonnées vous inquiétez
pas madame ici allez-y c'est tout il ya
que vous eh ben alors voilà donc enfin
côtoya il ya trois jours vous étiez du
métier sont celles où vous allez partir
300 jours on aura
mais chez ses rivaux pourri je veux dire
quelque chose parce que ça pis j'ai été
fier de votre décision vous avez soutenu
menem jusqu'au bout à vos travaux
[Applaudissements]